social distancing rules were ignored as
the 15 activists arrived at court hemmed
in by media supporters and opponents one
defendant striking a defiant those
appearing in court include the
figureheads of Hong Kong's democracy
movement like the lawyer and former
politician Martin Lee now 81 and
frequently vilified in China's state
controlled media as is Margaret own
another lawyer and campaigner the
newspaper owner and businessman Jimmy
Lai believes the arrests were ordered by
China's government and are intended as a
deterrent against future mass gatherings
well I think it's obvious that they just
want to intimidate you know the people
here that they won't they won't dare to
come out with demonstrate again Hong
Kong's police deny the charges are
politically motivated and insist they're
just doing their job nearly eight
thousand people have been arrested since
the start of the protests last June but
the roundup of some of the territory's
most respected campaigners a month ago
shocked many under a colonial-era law
they were charged with taking part in an
illegal assembly if found guilty they
face up to five years in jail the
hearing was adjourned until the middle
of next month these court appearances
come ahead of some very sensitive
anniversaries in Hong Kong and just days
before controversial legislation is due
to be presented to Hong Kong's fractious
legislature
and that legislature was a combative
place on Monday with MPs physically
fighting for control of an important
committee fourteen from the
pro-democracy parties were expelled from
the chamber they now face the prospect
of criminal charges which could despair
them from standing in elections later
this year Adrian Brown al-jazeera
Hongkong